one of the things we do on YouTube is we
are trying to make complex things simple
we are trying to take 8 hours of
research and put in into an 8 minute
video well the only way to do that is if
you master and learn the law of
Simplicity we're trying to take eight
years of experience and put it into a 45
minute longer form YouTube video or a
web class of some kind the only way you
do that is not by being more verbose and
more complex and adding more information
you actually do that effectively
by simplifying content down and a lot of
the channels I review or the creators
that I give feedback to struggle because
they're overc communicating they're
adding too much information a lot of
times their content is full of too much
data not enough story they have not
distilled down the content and according
to Einstein if you can't explain
something simply you got to work harder
you might not understand it well enough
so I really emphasized and it stood out
to me that John maxw was like effective
simple communication requires
significant effort if you think this is
hard good because it is and the reason
you'll be rewarded with views and
subscribers and channel growth is
because you did something really hard
you processed and you thought and you
wrote it and you rewrote it and when you
when it wasn't quite quite clear you
kept working until the clarity was
tangible you're like well that's very
complex and I found a simple way to
communicate that also remember that the
most effective messaging
when it comes
to the internet social media this is one
of the points Clarity be should be the
first goal if an ath grader can't
understand and explain your message it
isn't simple enough law of simplicity so
you're going to see bigger growth on
your YouTube channel if you've been
communicating maybe at a too complex
level 10th grade 12th grade PhD well
there's a reason why it's not working at
a broad appeal level because if you're
an eth grader can't understand it then
make it simple simpler Clarity should be
your first goal and I love this quote
from woodro Wilson he was asked how long
will it take you to prepare to give a
great talk or a public speech and he
said it depends if I am to speak for 10
minutes I need a week for Preparation if
15 minutes I need three days if a half
an hour two days if an hour I am ready
now let that sink
in if I am to speak for 10 minutes I
need a week for Preparation 10 minutes
is a YouTube video if I am to speak for
an hour I can do it right now one hour
is a live stream what's the point it's
crazy that this this quote was said
before YouTube existed it just speaks to
high quality
communication is challenging and if you
want to make 10 viral minutes of content
on YouTube imagine if you put a week
into that if you don't you understand
your message but you really aren't
refining it well hey let's go live right
now and just you know chat take 60
minutes to get the message across man
it's something powerful about that quote
that I think could apply to what it is
we are doing great communicators
prioritize simplifying complex ideas
Simplicity is the Hallmark of powerful
communication Winston Churchill and JFK
were praised for their clear and
Powerful speeches effective
communication is about conveying clear
powerful ideas CS Lewis emphasized
translating thoughts into accessible
language suggesting that if you can't
your thoughts may be confused so can you
translate your complex topic or
difficult to understand topic into
everyday accessible
language and if you can't maybe you need
to work harder to distill your thoughts
into more accessible communication espe
especially if you want broader appeal
and bigger impact on YouTube brevity is
crucial impactful statements often
require fewer words like the Lord's
Prayer or the Gettysburg Address short
speeches often require more preparation
effective communication is about concise
impactful content not length John M's
law of Simplicity stresses the
importance of focusing communication
remove the unnecessary highlight the
essential imagine if on your next video
you removed the unnecessary and you
highlighted the essential practicing the
law of Simplicity and communication
means less is more and Clarity is power
John Maxwell suggest that we should
deliver messages simply slowly and with
a smile for effective communication of
course you have to have your own style
and you might say but Sean aren't we
doing jump cuts and talking crazy like
crazy YouTubers and I think that you've
got to understand your audience you've
got to understand your style of content
and different mediums require different
methods but there is something powerful
that if the content is Rich and
clear and specific and poignant that
sometimes slowing down doesn't mean that
you're going to lose the audience's
attention if the video is
boring if the video lacks substance if
the video lacks research well it doesn't
matter how fast or slow you go and so I
think there's something there as it
pertains to delivering your messages
simply slowly and with a smile for
effective communication and great
communicators turn complex topics into
simple Concepts if you enjoyed this
content and want to take your YouTube
channel to the next level just click or
tap the link on the screen or go to tube
1K challenge.com to join our next live
YouTube challenge you'll learn our best
tips and strategies that are working
here at think media and I think you'll
love it